The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, welcome back.
Today, we start a
series of lectures
on approximation algorithms.
So something rather
different, although
we're still going to
be doing reductions.
They're just going to be
stronger sense of reductions.
So let me start
with reminding you--
I assume you've
seen approximation
algorithms at some
level before, but I
want to define a few
things which we'll
need for the lower bound side.
So pretty much throughout, we've
been-- in the context of NP,
we've been thinking
about decision problems,
because that's
where NP make sense.
Now, we need to change the
setup to where the output is
not just yes or no,
but it's some kind
of solution with a cost.
So in general, the goal
in an optimization problem
is going to be to go
from some instance
to a solution with
min or max cost.
So there's
minimization problems,
maximization problems.
And so you are given--
in order to specify this,
you're given a set of
possible instances.
That's your usual
notion of input.
And then for each instance, we
are given a set of solutions.
Usually, these are
called feasible
solutions or valid solutions.
I'll just call them solutions.
Those are the allowable
outputs to that problem.
And then for each
of those solutions,
we're going to define some cost.
I will assume that
they are non-negative,
so I don't have to
worry about signs.
And then you're
also given what's
usually called the objective,
which is either min or max.
OK, so you're going to be
given an item from this set.
You want to produce an item
from this set that minimizes
or maximizes this cost.
That's not going to be possible,
because all these problems are
going to be NP complete.
But the point of
approximation is
to relax getting
the best solution,
and aim to get an approximately
best solution, which
we will define in a moment.
But let me start with some
useful notation, which
is opt of x, x is an instance,
this is going to be two things.
No definition should
be unambiguous.
So it's going to be the cost
of a min or a max solution.
Cost solution.
And it's also going to be such
a solution itself, sometimes.
Cool.
So this is sort of
the usual setup.
Now let's make it a little bit
more interesting by defining
an NP optimization problem.
This is going to be the
analog of NP for optimization.
So one thing is
that all solutions
have polynomial length,
polynomial in the length
of the input, the instance.
Another thing is that
instances and solutions
can be recognized.
So there's a polynomial
time algorithm
that tells you yes,
that's a solution, yes,
that's an instance, or no.
And let's see, the
cost function should
be polynomially-computable.
And that's it.
OK, so just making
these actually
reasonable from an
algorithmic standpoint.
And so now, you know,
thinking like NP,
the solution is going to be
something like the certificate
that you had a yes answer.
Here, it's going to be a
certificate that the cost is
a particular thing.
So given an empty
optimization problem,
you can define a
decision problem,
or decision version of NPO.
So NPO is going to be the
class of all such problems, NP
optimization problems.
Just like NP was
all the problems
solvable in nondeterministic
polynomial time.
These things I claim, if
we convert to the decision
version, which is for a min
problem, the question is
is opt of x, the cost, less than
or equal to some query value.
And for a max
version, it is is opt
of x greater than or
equal to the query value.
This thing is an NP.
So let's see why.
If you have these properties,
then the resulting decision
problem will be an NP because
if I give you a solution,
and solutions have
polynomial length,
you can compute its cost, verify
that it was a valid solution,
and then you know that
opt-- opt is some min,
so it's going to be
less than or equal
to any particular solution.
So if I give you a solution,
then I verify that opt of x
is less than or equal
to q in polynomial time.
For max, it's the reverse.
And for example, if
you wanted to check--
if you wanted to know
whether the min was
greater than or
equal to something,
well that's a co NP problem.
So that's-- these are the
correct decision versions
of those NP optimization
problems in the sense that you
get a problem in NP.
So this is a strict
generalization, in some sense,
of NP problems, or
specialization I suppose.
This is a particular-- well,
we have optimization versions
which still give us NP problems.
We can still talk about NP
completeness of these problems.
But we're interested--
we're setting all this up
so we can actually talk about
costs of not just the best
solution, but costs of
suboptimal solutions.
So let's get to approximation.
So we're going to call
an algorithm, ALG, a c
approximation.
I write c, but it's not
necessarily a constant.
It could be a function of
N. If-- in the min case,
what we want is the cost
of the algorithm applied
to an input, x, divided by
the cost of the optimal of x.
Here, for whatever
reason, I write cost
of opt instead of just opt.
That should be less
than or equal to c.
We look at the ratio,
we want that to be
bounded by some value.
In the max case, there
are two definitions
that are standard in
the literature that
correspond to different ways
of looking at the same thing.
One would be cost of OPT
divided by cost of ALG.
That should be, at most, c.
This would correspond to c being
greater than or equal to 1.
And the alternative is to
flip the inequality instead
of the ratio.
First, let's think about min.
With a minimization problem,
whatever the algorithm produces
will be greater than
or equal to OPT.
So this is a ratio that will
give something greater than
or equal to 1.
And so usually we think
about two approximation,
1.5 approximation,
100 approximation,
whatever, just saying
the algorithm is
within a factor of
100 of the optimal.
For maximization, the thing
that the algorithm produces
will be less than
or equal to OPT.
And so if you want something
that is greater than 1,
you have to flip the ratio.
In this situation, c would
be less than or equal to 1.
So some people call-- if
you have an algorithm that
produces a solution that is
at least 1/2 times optimal,
you might call it
a two approximation
or you might call it
a 1/2 approximation,
depending on the paper.
I think this is, by
now, more common,
but it really depends on the
era and the person and so on.
So good to be aware of both.
It's measuring the
same thing, of course,
just c is either bigger
than 1 or less than 1.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that
over all instances?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah, this
should be for all x.
For all valid instances x.
Good.
So usually when we say a
c approximation algorithm,
usually we're interested in
polynomial time c approximation
algorithm.
Almost all the time
that is the case.
I will probably forget
to say polynomial time,
but I always mean it
unless I say otherwise,
which will probably be never.
But there are a few papers
that look at exponential time
approximation algorithms
that have better
exponent than the exact
counterparts, and so on.
So this is interesting
because while
your-- the straight-up decision
problem, which is basically
deciding OPT exactly,
that might be NP complete.
The approximation version,
like finding a two
approximate solution,
might be polynomial.
And that would be observed
by finding a polynomial
to approximation algorithm.
Sometimes you can do even
better than con-- well.
So here, we've been thinking
about constant factors for c.
Sometimes you can do even
better than any constant factor,
or you can achieve any
constant factor would
be another way of saying it.
This is called a polynomial time
approximation scheme, usually
PTAS.
You can think of this as a
1 plus epsilon approximation
for any epsilon.
But the general-- or
you can think of it
as an algorithm that,
given epsilon, produces a 1
plus epsilon
approximation algorithm.
Or you can think of
it as an algorithm
with an additional input, not
just the instance, but also
a value epsilon.
It's a rational epsilon
greater than zero.
And then the-- let's say
produces a solution that's
a 1 plus epsilon approximation.
So this would be a sort
of ideal situation.
You get to specify what
the error bound is,
and the algorithm will
find a suitable solution.
And the polynomial time
part is that this algorithm
must be polynomial time for
any fixed epsilon, which
means that the dependence on
epsilon could be horrible.
You could have an
algorithm, if N
is your input size, that runs
in something like N to the 2
to the 2 to the 1 over
epsilon or whatever.
That's polynomial time for
any fixed value of epsilon.
It's rather large for any
reasonable value of epsilon,
like a half, but anyway.
Or even 1 is still
getting up there.
But that's considered a P test.
Now there are stronger
notions of P tests
that prevent this kind of thing.
We will get to that when
we get to fixed parameter
tractability.
But for now, this would be
considered the gold standard.
This is the best you could hope
for at this level of detail.
And for-- let me give
you some more classes.
So we defined NPO.
There's the class PTAS.
Again, reuse of term, but this
is all problems-- NPO problems
with a PTAS algorithm.
And more generally, if we
have some class of functions,
then I'm going to write
FAPX to be all the NPO
problems with poly-time f
approximation algorithms.
I'll write f of N
to be clear what
we're depending on for some
little f in the class big F.
So for example, f
of N could be 3.
That would be a constant
factor approximation.
In that case, we
just call it APX.
APX is what you might otherwise
call order one APX, things
that you can approximate
in some constant factor,
any constant factor.
Another class that's
commonly studied is log APX.
This is log N approximable
some constant factor.
And there are more.
There's poly APX,
where you just want
N to some constant, usually
less than one but not always.
But I think this will
be enough for us.
And so we're interested in
distinguishing these classes.
We're going to do that by
defining reductions, using
reductions, defining hardness,
and then getting the hardest
problems in certains
of these classes
to show that's the best kind
of approximability you can get.
Today, we'll be thinking in
particular about the boundary
between PTAS and APX.
So PTAS, we can get 1 plus
epsilon for any epsilon.
APX, you can get
a constant factor,
but there's some
limit to how small
that constant factor could be,
at least in the hardest case.
APX includes PTAS, but there's
problems in APX minus PTAS.
Those have a limit how
far down you can get.
OK.
We have PTAS is a subset of APX.
And furthermore, if P is not
equal NP, it's a strict subset.
And let's say log
APX or whatever.
You pick your favorite
approximation factor,
and there are problems
where you can achieve
that and nothing better.
It's actually an easy exercise
to come up with such a thing.
This is if P does not equal NP.
So you can take, I don't know,
Hamiltonian cycle or something,
or pick your favorite
NP hard problem.
And if the answer is
yes to that problem,
then you construct a
solution with some cost.
And if the answer is no,
it's way, way smaller.
And so any approximation
within your desired factor
will be hard to find.
Let me get a little bit more
specific, and let's talk
about some real problems.
So in the world of graph
algorithm approximability,
these are the typical kinds of
approximation factors you see.
Of course, it depends
exactly what subdomain.
This is not a complete list, but
it starts to give you a flavor.
And today, we'll be thinking
mostly at the top level.
But let me define some of
these problems for you.
A lot of them we have seen,
or a few of them we have seen,
such as Steiner tree.
We talked about
rectilinear Steiner tree.
That was a Euclidean problem.
You were given
points in the plane,
and you wanted to
connect them up
by the shortest
connected network.
In a graph-- so that problem
has a PTAS rectilinear Steiner
tree, because it's
a Euclidean problem.
A lot of Euclidean
problems have PTAS's.
And I'm denoting PTAS
here by 1 plus epsilon.
In general, epsilon here
means for all epsilon greater
than zero.
Steiner tree in a graph
is I give you a graph
and you have a bunch of special
vertices, k special vertices.
You want to find a
connected subgraph
of that graph that hits all
of the special vertices.
That problem has a constant
factor approximation,
and there's no PTAS
for a general graph.
Steiner forest is
almost the same.
Instead of giving
vertices that all
have to connect to each other,
you say which pairs of vertices
need to connect to each other.
This guy and this guy,
and this guy and this guy.
You can still-- this
is a generalization.
In the case where you want to
connect them in a [? Kleek ?]
pattern, that's Steiner tree.
But Steiner forest has
the same approximability
up to constant factors.
Traveling salesman
in a graph, you've
probably seen a 1.5
approximation to that.
Definitely two approximation
is really easy, like MST.
And that's-- for in a graph,
that's the best you can do
in 2D.
Or in a planar graph or
in an H-minor free graph,
there's a PTAS.
I think H-minor free, traveling
salesman problem weighted was
solved just a couple years ago.
But that has a PTAS.
Let's see.
Usually most people
like to think
about minimization
problems, but there
are maximization problems, too.
Let's see, what else
haven't I defined.
Did we talk about set cover?
You have-- I think
we did briefly.
You have sets and
you have elements.
You want to choose the fewest
sets that hits all elements.
Each set contains
some of the elements.
You can think of it as a
bipartite graph, sets on one
side, elements on the other.
You want to choose
the fewest vertices
on the left that hit all
the vertices on the right.
Dominating set is the
non-bipartite version
of that problem.
You're just given a graph.
And if you choose a vertex,
it covers that vertex
and its neighboring vertices.
And your goal is to
cover all vertices
using the smallest
dominating set,
by choosing the fewest vertices.
So these problems turn
out to be equivalent from
an approximability standpoint.
And in a stronger sense,
they're both log N approximable,
and that's the best you can do.
This is assuming p
does not equal NP.
Some of these results assume
slightly stronger things
than p versus NP, but we won't
worry about that too much.
Let's see.
Another fun problem-- I'm
just highlighting the ones you
should know about.
Chromatic number,
we've seen what we
thought about three coloring.
But the chromatic
number problem is
to minimize the
number of colors, k,
such that your graph
is k-colorable.
And that's really
hard to approximate.
The best approximation
algorithm, I think,
is N divided by log N,
or something roughly N.
That's not so good.
And there's a lower
bound that you
can't do better than N to the 1
minus epsilon for all epsilon.
So you really--
that's pretty tight.
Not completely tight,
but pretty close.
And let's see.
Other good problems.
So maybe out here, another
really hard problem
to approximate--
these are problems
you should try to
avoid if you're trying
to solve things approximately.
Or if you're driving
hardness, you'd
want to use these if you can,
if your problem looks like this.
Independence set,
just find me a set
of vertices that
induce no edges.
So no edges connecting them.
That's really hard.
If you complement the
graph everywhere there's
an edge deleted and
everywhere there
wasn't an edge added, that's
the same problem as Kleek.
So these are the same also from
an approximation standpoint.
OK.
This is annoying
because [? Kleeks ?]
are useful in practice, but.
There's another problem
called [? densest ?] subgraph,
which is approximate
[? Kleeks. ?] That's actually
easier to approximate.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the
hardness of something
for the chromatic
number lower bound?
PROFESSOR: I think that's
like P does not equal ZPP,
or NP does not
equal ZPP, I think.
Yeah.
For that-- that's
strong lower bounds.
There are weaker lower bounds
assuming P does not equal NP.
OK.
One other good one, fun one,
to think about is set cover.
You want to choose the fewest
sets to hit all elements.
Maximum coverage, you don't
have to hit all the elements
but you want to hit as
many elements as possible
using k sets.
So in the decision
problem, these
are the same in some sense.
Here, I give you k sets.
I want to know can I
hit all the elements.
For example, here
I'm giving k sets
and I want to know can I hit
at least J of the elements.
So this you could think is a
generalization from a decision
standpoint, but
it's actually easier
to approximate because the
objective is different.
Here we have to hit every
element, no questions asked.
Here, it's OK if we miss
some of the elements
because we only need a
constant factor approximation.
And we can get a
constant factor here,
whereas the best we
can do is log N here.
Cool.
But unique coverage,
this is a result of ours.
If you're trying to
maximize coverage
but if you double
cover an element,
you no longer get points for it.
That requires log
N approximation.
So I think I will
leave it at that.
Directed graphs are much
harder, although it's not
known exactly how hard.
Here's an example of a big gap
in what we between log squared
and N to the epsilon.
Something we will get
to in a later class
is called label cover.
I won't define the
problem here, because it
takes a while to define.
But there, there's very
strong lower bounds
on-- in approximability.
It's similar to N to the 1
minus epsilon, but it's not.
It's a little smaller.
So you see 2 to the log N would
be N. That would be great.
And so you'd really
like 2 to the log N
to the 1 minus epsilon.
But what we have here is
something a little smaller
than log N, log N to the
1 minus epsilon power.
And then you exponentiate that.
So this is somewhat smaller
than what we'd actually like,
which is something like N to the
1 minus-- or N to some epsilon,
I guess, would be ideal.
This is smaller than
any N to the epsilon.
The best upper bounds, it
depends on the problem.
With N to some constant,
like for label cover,
it's N to the 1/3.
For directed Steiner
forest, which
is you have pairs
of vertices you
want to connect, but
with a directed path.
So similar to a
problem we've seen.
Best approximation
known for that
is N to the 4/5 plus epsilon.
And this is just a
couple years ago.
So that seems very hard to
do better than any constant.
Probably there's an N to
the epsilon lower bound,
but this is the best we
know so far, a bit smaller.
Cool.
Any questions about that table?
We will probably come back to it
a few times, but in more depth.
So how do you prove
the lower bound side?
We're going to use reductions.
Now this field is a little bit
messier in terms of reductions.
For NP completeness,
NP hardness, we just
worried about [? carp ?]
style, one call reductions.
That's all we had
to think about.
In this universe, there
are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9-- at least nine
definitions of reduction.
You don't need to know them all.
I will define four
of them, I think.
They're all very
similar, and they all
lead to slightly different
notions of hardness.
So you have to be
a little careful
when you say oh, this
problem is something hard.
But I'll give you
some definitions
that are pretty easy
to work with, I think.
In general, this
family is called
approximation-preserving
reductions.
So let's say we want to
go from some problem A
to some problem B. So you're
given an instance of A,
let's call it x, and you want to
produce an instance of B. Let's
call it x prime.
And we're going to do
that by a function f,
so x prime is f of x.
So far, just like NP reductions.
But now-- usually what we said
is that the answer to x equals
the answer to x prime.
So you could say OPT of x
equals the OPT of x prime.
But that's not going
to be strong enough.
What we want is that, if we
can find a solution to this B
problem-- let's call it
y-prime to the problem x-prime.
So the x-prime is
an instance of B.
You can find some solution-- any
solution y-prime-- to x-prime,
then we want to be
able to convert it
back by a function, g,
into a solution to A, which
we'll call y.
And so it's g-- you might
think it's g of y-prime,
but we'll make it g
of x comma y prime.
So it can also depend on
what you started with.
So this is the general flavor.
A reduction consists
of two steps.
First, like before, we
convert instances of A
to instances of B.
Now in addition,
we want to be able to
recover solutions of B
into similarly good
solutions to A.
And there's many ways to
define similarly good.
Let me give you one.
So if we're just interested
in PTAS's, then--
like you want to know does
my problem have a PTAS
or I want to prove
impossibility of PTAS's, then
I think there's one clear
notion of reduction,
which is obviously enough
called PTAS reduction.
So what we want to say is--
I hope you've seen calculus
at some point.
In calculus, there's this
notion of epsilon delta proofs,
or definitions.
So I'm going to say-- you don't
have to think of it this way,
but I find it useful to
think of it this way.
Let me get to what
the statement is.
If y-prime is a 1 plus
delta approximation to B,
then y is a 1 plus epsilon
approximation to A.
So ultimately we're
interested in PTAS's, and we
want to say that if you
have a PTAS for B, then
you get a PTAS for A.
It used to be, when we
did a reduction from A
to B, that showed that if B had
a polynomial time algorithm,
then so did A, because you just
plug in these chains together.
You convert A into
the B instance,
you run your poly algorithm
and get a solution,
and convert it back.
Well, with NP, we didn't
even have to convert.
The answer was the same.
Now we could do that.
We want to do the same
thing with PTAS's.
So if we have a PTAS for
B, we can convert A into B,
run the PTAS, get a solution,
and come back and get--
what we want is for it
to be a 1 plus epsilon
approximation to A.
So that's the goal,
1 plus epsilon approximation.
And what this is
saying is there's
some function delta of
epsilon-- for any epsilon,
there's some value
delta where you
can give that value
to the PTAS for B,
and it will give you
what you want for A.
Because PTAS is supposed to
run for any fixed constant--
we called it epsilon, but
it could also be delta.
And so you plug in
this to the PTAS.
You will get a 1 plus
delta approximation
to your B problem.
And then what we want is
that this conversion-- so y
here is g of xy-prime.
So we want g-- this
is a constraint on g.
We want g to have the property
that if y-prime is that good,
then y will still be
as good as we need.
So maybe you just-- you want
to get a 1.1 approximation.
You want to get within
10% of the right answer.
Maybe you have to call B
with a much smaller thing.
Maybe delta is 0.01.
You need to be within
1% of the right answer.
But there's-- for
a PTAS reduction,
you want there to be some
approximability you asked
for so that you get
what you actually want.
This is sort of the obvious--
this the natural thing
if you want to preserve
PTAS-ness in this direction,
from B to A.
One slight note is
that we also allow f
and g to depend on epsilon.
So this reduction-- it
would be hard to get
this property for all epsilon
with the same instance
conversion.
So now we allow the
conversion of the instances
to depend on epsilon, so you
can do fun things that way
for the purposes
of PTAS reductions.
But the key thing we get is
that if B is a PTAS, then--
or has a PTAS--
then A as a PTAS,
so it's in the
complexity class PTAS.
Of course, what we care about
is the contrapositive of that.
So if A is not in PTAS,
then B is not in PTAS.
So we can use this-- we
reduced from our hard problem
that we know is not in PTAS,
assuming P does not equal NP,
and we get that our new
problem B is not in PTAS.
That's the point.
This is also true for
something like APX.
So if you just want constant
factor approximation,
this will convert
one constant factor
into another constant factor.
So yeah, if you
have-- I mean, it's
maybe stronger than what
you need, but will give you
constant factor
approximations, as well.
So here's some easy
more definitions.
Oh, OK, so a few more fun facts.
If this statement
also holds true
for epsilon equals 0 when you
plug in epsilon equals zero,
delta equals zero,
then you're just
getting the regular notion
of reduction from NP land.
This is saying the
OPTs are equal.
So usually your solution
also works in that setting.
That's usually the
easy thing to do.
So this is a strictly stronger
notion of NP reduction
if you allow the 0,0 case.
Also, reductions change.
So if A reduces to B
and B reduces to C,
then A reduces to C. All the
usual things you'd expect.
Some special cases of
interest are AP reduction.
This is when the delta
function is linear in epsilon.
So this is nice because
it tells you, for example,
if B is in-- has some order
f approximation, then A does,
as well.
It just changes this
constant factor.
So this is useful if you care
about log N approximation.
If you use this
definition, things
could change, because
you're allowed
to change what the factor
is out here in crazy ways.
So over here, [? before-- ?] so
[? it's ?] just a linear blow
up in the approximation factor,
then we only lose constant
factors in approximability.
And one more is
strict reduction.
This is when there's no blowup.
If you have a c
approximation here,
you get a c approximation there.
That's nice when you can get it.
We're not going to aim
for this in particular,
but there are a
bunch of reductions
we'll talk about
today that are strict.
So it's nice to just have a word
to say oh, this is even strict.
You don't even need any
[? blowup ?] like this stuff.
So that was strict AP
and PTAS reductions.
There's one more, but maybe
first let me define hardness.
So today, we will
focus on APX hardness.
And these are supposed to be
the hardest problems in APX.
And so, I mean,
because we're trying
to distinguish between
PTAS-able problems and just
constant factor
approximable problems,
we are interested
in PTAS reductions.
So it's going to turn out
that APX hard-- well I
guess we sort of already know.
This implies you're not in PTAS
if P equals NP-- P does not
equal NP-- because of
this strict containment,
P does not equal NP, then
PTAS is different from APX.
And so if you show your
hardest problem in APX,
using a reduction that
preserves PTAS-ability,
then you know-- I mean, the
idea is that-- all right.
When we're doing
these reductions,
we know that if B had a
PTAS then A had a PTAS.
And what we're saying is you
can re-- your APX hard means
you can reduce from any
problem in APX to your problem.
So if your problem had a PTAS,
that would mean all problems
had PTAS's.
All APX problems had PTAS's.
But we know that's not the case.
Therefore, your problem
does not have a PTAS.
So it's just like
MP completeness,
just with different letters.
Cool.
And different reductions.
These reductions
are all a little
bit awkward to work
with directly for--
or these definitions
are a little awkward
to check directly, although
ultimately it's the same thing.
In practice, people seem
to use a different notion
of reduction, for the most
part, called L reductions.
That's stronger than AP
reduction, not as strong
as strict.
I guess it's not directly
related either way to strict,
but, it's OK.
So while I define this in
terms of PTAS reduction,
because that's what you
need to get this result,
most people think
about L reduction,
which is going to imply--
it's going to be stronger
than the other two notions
of reduction, AP and PTAS.
So what's the definition?
We want to satisfy
two properties.
The first property is a kind
of blowup, going left to right.
Funnily enough, the
other reductions
do not have this property,
because they don't quite
need it in the way
that they're going.
But we want that the transform
problem, its optimal solution
is not much bigger.
It's bigger by only
a constant factor.
This is, like, less
than or equal to alpha
times the optimal-- the
original optimal solution given
instance, so A.
Second property--
and we'll see why we
need this in a moment--
is if you look at the
absolute error instead
of the ratio between the
computed solution y--
and y was the thing that we
got in the lower left corner,
we produced the solution
y-- we look at the cost
that we get out of--
y is the solution.
So we look at the
cost of that solution,
we compare it to
the optimal solution
to our original
instance-- because it
is a solution to that instance.
That should not be much
bigger than the error
on the right side.
Again, absolute error.
So we want this to be big O of
cost in B's problem of y-prime
minus OPT of B of x prime.
So these are both in B land.
Again, we look at
the optimal solution
to the produced instance
versus some solution
that we were given.
We didn't produce
that solution, so this
has to hold no matter
what solution y-prime
you're given to the instance
x-prime, when you convert it
using g to a solution
to x in problem A,
you want that the gap--
absolute gap-- is not stretched
by more than a constant factor.
Again, this is at most some
constant times [? that ?]
[? thing ?].
OK?
Now it should not be obvious
that this implies this,
but it does, with delta equal
to, I think-- get some color.
Let's say the constant
in here is alpha,
the constant here is beta.
And this should be alpha
times beta times epsilon.
That is delta of epsilon.
That's the claim.
Let's prove the claim,
ideally without cheating.
So I claim that if I
have such an L reduction,
that this holds where-- when
delta is that linear function
of epsilon.
So I want to conclude that y
is a pretty good approximation.
So to do that, I will look at
the cost of y divided by OPT.
OPT of X would be
the original input.
So we want to show that this
is, at most, 1 plus epsilon.
Now what do we know?
I should write A, I
guess, because this
is all about problem
A. What do we know?
We know this property-- I
wrote absolute value here,
so this works for
maximization and minimization.
You can even
convert minimization
to maximization problems
using this definition.
We will do that at some point.
OK.
So let's just try to
plug this into here.
So I think I need
to split into cases,
and I'll just worry about
the minimization case.
So let's say that cost
of A is bigger than OPT.
So then cost of A is going to
be OPT plus this thing, at most.
So this is going to be at
most OPT of x plus beta--
I'm going to not use
the big O notation,
and just write the beta thing.
Beta times-- I guess there's
no absolute value needed,
because this is a
minimization problem.
Let's say-- so this will be cos
sub B of y-prime minus OPT of B
of x-prime.
So that's what I get from
expanding out the numerator,
and the denominator is the same.
Clear?
Just rearranging terms
here, essentially.
OK.
Now these two terms cancel,
so we get 1 plus that.
That's good, because I
wanted that to be epsilon.
Let's see.
What else do we know.
It's 1 plus this thing.
Let me scroll down.
OK, we have one other property.
We've got to use it.
The other property
is that OPT sub
B is related to OPT sub A.
Now we have OPT sub A here,
but it's in the denominator,
which flips the relation.
So we can write that relation
up there as OPT sub A of x
is omega of OPT
sub B of x-prime.
That's the same
as statement one.
And because the
denominator is omega,
that means the whole thing is
big L. So this is going to be,
at most, one plus-- so
now we have this thing.
So the numerator is the same.
We had before beta times
cost sub B of y-prime minus
OPT sub B of x-prime.
So that's unchanged.
But now, instead of
dividing by OPT sub A,
we're going to divide
by OPT sub B of x-prime.
And we lost a constant factor,
that constant factor translated
to B alpha in the
numerator because we
inverted the equation.
We divided by the
constant factor there.
So what-- well now
this cancels with that.
So this is going
to be 1 plus alpha
beta times cost sub B y-prime
over OPT sub B of x-prime
minus 1.
Still looks kind of weird.
But what we-- there's
one more thing
we didn't use, which is we
assumed the-- we were given
some solution y-prime that
was a 1 plus delta of epsilon
approximation, where
delta is this thing
that we defined there.
It's obviously set to cancel out
everything that happened here.
So this thing should be,
at most, 1 plus delta,
because this is exactly
the approximation
ratio for y-prime versus the
optimal solution to x-prime.
And 1 plus delta is 1
plus alpha beta epsilon.
So this 1 cancels with that
1, these alpha betas-- whoops.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's backwards.
PROFESSOR: Which is backwards?
The definition of delta?
OK.
Whoops.
Let's try epsilon
over alpha beta.
That makes sense, because delta
should be smaller than epsilon
probably, and alpha and beta
are probably bigger than 1.
So now we get epsilon
over alpha beta here.
And then that alpha beta
cancels with that alpha beta,
and we are left
with 1 plus epsilon.
OK.
So this is why it's not
obvious, but it's just plugging
in all the things and it works.
And the funny thing is,
somehow L reductions,
though they-- a little bit
less natural, I feel like.
I mean, if you're thinking about
constant factor approximation,
why should you care
about absolute error?
The short answer that I've
seen written in various papers
is because it's easier
to think that way
for a lot of the typical
reductions that you do.
So let us do some
of those reductions.
And we'll get some intuition.
L reductions also-- they
do work in the zero case.
If you have an optimal
solution to x-prime,
you will get an
optimal solution to x.
So they are also NP reductions.
Again, that's a generalization
of-- or strengthening
of the type of reduction we
saw in all previous lectures.
All right.
So I want to
simultaneously tell you
a bunch of problems
that are APX complete so
that you know things
to reduce from,
but also I'll show you
examples of such things.
So some of these I will omit the
proofs, because they're messy
and it's just useful to
know that they're there
so you can reduce from them.
Others I-- most of them,
I will cover the proofs.
All right.
And we're going to
return to an old issue
from the first SAT lecture.
And I'm going to introduce
some new notation.
So a lot of the starting
points here are just max SAT.
Or I should-- let's
say a max CNF SAT.
You're given a CNF formula.
It's picked out a
bunch of clauses.
You want to maximize
the number of clauses
that you satisfy with
some variable assignment.
So that's going to
be APX complete.
There are constant
factor approximations
if the clauses are constant
size, I should say.
So like max 3SAT has a
constant factor approximation,
I forget what the
current best is.
And no better.
There's no PTAS for a max 3SAT.
This is a stronger
form of max 3SAT,
which we have not seen before,
though we've hinted around it.
The E means every
clause has exactly
three distinct literals.
This is an issue that
we stumbled into.
Oh, do we allow clauses
to have only two literals?
I said no, in the
original definition.
But I did allow
repeated literals,
which is the same thing.
So when I say three set, I
mean you can repeat literals,
or you can have fewer
than three literals.
When I say E three set, then
you're not allowed to do that.
Then you may remember we
talked about 3SAT five.
That meant every clause
has only three literals,
and every variable appears,
at most, five times.
E5 means exactly five times.
Each variable appears
exactly five times.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
gives you a condition
on the number of clauses.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're right.
That gives you a linear relation
between the number of clauses
and the number of variables.
You can work it out.
This is hard.
I will not prove it.
It's not hard, but it's
just a little bit messy.
Sorry.
It's not difficult.
I will prove a slightly
different result, which
this one is based on, which
is a little bit more familiar
but also introduces something
new we hadn't seen before.
This is the regular 3SAT.
Each clause has, at
most, three literals.
And every variable appears,
at most, three times.
This is something I
didn't realize was hard.
It's not written in most places.
But it is here, in the
world of approximability.
This is the reduction.
It's kind of funny.
So suppose you
have a variable, x,
which appears a million times.
You're going to make
a cycle, so to speak.
It's a formula,
so it's not really
a cycle, but of size 1 million.
And you're going to write down
this 2SAT constraint-- not xi
or xi plus 1 for all i.
And do it around in
the cycle, so not x6
or x1-- or x a million or x1.
That's, of course, equivalent
to saying if xi is set to true,
then xi plus 1 must
also be set to true.
So if any of these are
set to true, they all are.
So the only
satisfying assignments
here are everybody true,
everybody not true.
So if you're just worried
about NP reductions,
this is a reduction
from 3SAT to 3SAT-3.
Because every variable
now will appear
in exactly three--
exactly three,
in fact-- so constraints.
This one, this one, and whatever
it originally-- whatever
you want to plug it into.
So each of these was an
occurrence of that variable.
Maybe use the positive form,
maybe use the negative form,
but each variable appears three
times in this first picture.
Now that's a great
reduction for 3SAT-3.
Notice I didn't write max,
because this reduction will not
work as an L reduction, say.
You cannot prove that max 3SAT
is hard using this reduction,
because you could, for
example, just violate these two
constraints and make all
of these guys true and all
of these guys false.
And if this is size
a million, that
means you're saying--
I mean, you're
setting the variable
half true, half false--
or you could use any ratio you
want-- at a very small cost.
You're only paying a penalty
of two constraints violated,
and yet you're able to satisfy
1/2 of the clauses using
xi equal to true, and
some other set of clauses
using xi set to false.
And there's no way to
bound how many clauses you
can sort of misrepresent.
And the objective in
max 3SAT is to maximize
the number of clauses satisfied.
So if you allow
this kind of thing
where you can flip in
crazy ways and change
a huge number of clauses one
way or the other in this sort
of false way, how
would-- if you're
trying to actually construct
a solution to max 3SAT
from a solution to
this 3SAT-3 instance,
you wouldn't know which way
to set the variable x to.
If you set it to true,
there's a whole bunch
of clauses that
wanted it to be false.
If you set it to false, a whole
bunch you wanted to be true.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If we're just
talking about NP hardness here,
can't you make those edges
very heavy by repeating
the clause many times?
PROFESSOR: If we're just
worried about NP hardness,
this is fine.
Because then all of
these have to be true.
AUDIENCE: Uh, I mean for
the max decision problem.
PROFESSOR: Well then
the decision problem
is, can you satisfy all of them.
That is a special
case of the max--
AUDIENCE: Satisfy k of--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but if
you set k equal to N,
that's a special case
of the general form.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: So--
AUDIENCE: I see
what you're saying.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If you didn't-- if you wanted
to make k and N different,
you could just add a bunch of
things that are unsatisfiable.
Lots of ways to change
how many there are.
OK.
Nonetheless, we can prove
max 3SAT-3 is hard with an L
reduction from 3SAT.
So I'm not going to prove
that 3SAT is APX hard.
We might do that in
a future lecture,
but just take that as given.
What I want to show you
is how to convert max 3SAT
into max 3SAT-3.
Not like this, but
using a different trick.
So reducing from max 3SAT.
We're given a formula,
we're given some variables.
Let's say-- let's
look at variable x.
And let's say it
appears k times.
What we're going to
do, just like before,
we're going to make
k new variables.
We're going to make k variables
x1 through xk that replace x,
and we're going to use
those instead of x.
And I want to force all the
values of x to be the same,
but I want to force it even when
you're allowed to cheat and set
some of the things incorrectly.
And we're going to do this
using a powerful tool, which
is good to know about,
called expander graphs.
So there's two
things to tell you.
One is, what is
an expander graph,
and the other thing is, once
I have an expander graph,
what do I do.
Let me start with the latter,
because it's a little simpler.
I guess a lot of you have
heard about expander graphs.
And the short answer is they're
complicated and confusing,
but really cool and powerful.
We're not going to try to prove
that expanders exist here.
I'm just going to
tell you they exist,
and that's actually
pretty simple
what they-- what
properties they have.
So what I want to do, whenever
I have an edge in this graph--
this is a graph
whose vertices are
the x1 through xk--
I'm going to convert
an edge into a constraint,
which is effectively
xi equals xj, which in
reality is not xi or xj,
and not xj or xi.
So I really probably shouldn't
think of it as xi equals xj.
That's what I want to do.
I want to force lots
of things to be equal.
But really, we have
to, in the end,
think about it in
terms of constraints,
because some of them
might be violated.
So what is an expander graph?
There are different types.
But what we will use
is two properties.
So this is for k nodes.
We have bounded degree, and
we have, for every cut AB--
and I think we've talked
about cuts in this context,
in the context of max cut.
So the idea is that
A and B are disjoint,
and their union is the
set of all vertices.
So A is 1 side of the cut, B
is the other side of the cut.
We want the number
of cross edges,
the number of edges
between A and B, is big.
It's at least the
min of A and B.
Some intuition.
Imagine a Kleek.
A [? Kleek ?] is
not bounded degree,
but it has this property.
If you look at any cut, there's
a lot of edges between them.
It's actually more
like the product.
But in particular,
it's at least the min.
So you can think of the expander
as a sparse [? Kleek. ?]
It's [? Kleek-y ?]
enough, in this sense,
which we'll see why this
is the property we want.
But it has bounded
degree, therefore
linear number of edges.
So it's very sparse.
In the construction
we are applying,
which is due to
[INAUDIBLE] Philips
and [? Sarnak, ?]
the degree is 14.
But it doesn't matter.
Constant.
It's actually 14
regular, so that's nice.
So we take this
graph, which was known
to be out there--
basically random
graphs [INAUDIBLE]
property, but we
won't worry about how
to construct it too
much, although you do have to.
But there's tons of papers
on how to construct them.
And then for every
edge, we convert it
into these two constraints.
So let's prove that
this is an L reduction.
Claim L reduction.
So maybe-- I don't have
anything to point at,
because I can't point
at an expander graph.
But let me draw the graph
so I can point at something.
Let's draw the
[? Kleek, ?] just so it's
a little easier to think about.
This is an expander, [? k4 ?].
And let's say, in your solution,
some of these end up getting
assigned true value--
let's represent that
by red-- some of them not.
Maybe three of them
are true, one of them
is false or whatever.
In general, I'm
going to choose--
so I mean, we're given
some solution, right?
This is the solution y-prime
to the constructed instance
x-prime.
X-prime has this expander.
So we look at a solution
y-prime to x-prime,
we have no control
over what it is.
If you look at a variable,
some fraction of them
are set to true, some of
them are set to false.
We're going to
choose the majority.
So here it's majority
red, so we're going
to change this guy to be red.
Now does that hurt us?
Well, we can think
of there as being
a cut of the red
nodes versus the not
red nodes, the black nodes.
And I claim the number
of edges here is big.
It's at least the
minimum of A and B.
Now what we were doing is
taking the minimum of A and B
and recoloring that side
to be the other side.
When we do that, we
have these constraints,
which are supposed to
be equality constraints.
These things are supposed to be
equal, but they weren't before.
Before I recolored this, these
were-- at least one constraint
here was violated, because
this one of them was red,
one of them was black.
When I fill this in,
I improve my solution,
because-- by at least
the size of the cut.
Each of these guys
now becomes satisfied.
It wasn't before.
So I improve my
solution by this much.
I also worsen my
solution, potentially,
because that node
appears in one clause.
And so it gets worse by 1.
So suppose there are B
nodes on the smaller side,
and we're recoloring B nodes.
So we got an improvement by
P, and also we worsened things
by up to P. Because these P guys
appear in P different clauses.
Each one potentially we mess
up is no longer satisfied.
But for every one that we mess
up-- so these guys up here
in some actual clause--
each one we mess up,
we also make at least
one thing happy.
Because we fixed the cut.
So if we have any solution,
we can convert it into one
where our variables are
all true or all false,
and not lose anything.
Therefore, there exists
an optimal solution.
There exists an
optimal solution.
And you do this variable by
variable, where variables
are all true or all false.
Now, we do change the
value of OPT here.
Because we added a
ton of constraints,
and we just said well the--
in the optimal solution,
or an optimal solution-- in
fact, all of these constraints
will be satisfied.
Which means OPT has increased.
So the OPT for
x-prime, this thing,
is going to be larger
than the OPT for x.
OPT of x-prime is going to
equal OPT of x plus order
the total number of occurrences
of all variables, which
is at most three times
the number of clauses.
So we want to know,
does it satisfy
this definition of L reduction.
We need to know that
the OPT does not explode
by more than a constant factor.
And yet, we added this big term.
But the good news
is, in 3SAT, you
can always satisfy a constant
fraction of the clauses.
So OPT is always at least--
I think I have written here,
like, half of them.
I think you just randomly
assign the variables,
and some constant fraction will
be satisfied in expectation.
So there's definitely a solution
where OPT of-- so OPT of x
is definitely at
least some constant
times the number of clauses.
And so this adding some constant
times the number of clauses
doesn't change the overall cos
by more than a constant factor.
So property one holds.
Property two holds, in
fact, with beta equal 1.
You're not making
your solution in-- you
see we have this additive
thing, because we
add these gadgets and stuff.
Multiplicatively,
it's confusing,
and that's what we were
worrying about here.
But additively, it's very clean.
We always add the exact same
amount to your solution.
So if you have a
solution y-prime
and you convert it
back to a solution y,
the gap-- the additive
gap between the cost
of y versus OPT of x will
be equal to the additive gap
between the cost of y-prime
versus OPT of x-prime.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So here,
how many times
are you using each variable?
PROFESSOR: We are using
each variable 29 times.
We're using it-- why 29?
Because-- right.
We have degree 14, but
then for every edge
we actually have
two constraints,
the implication
[? in ?] both ways.
So that's 28.
Plus the vari--
each of those nodes
actually appears in
one actual clause.
OK.
So this proves that
max 3SAT-29 is hard.
Yep, good question.
Why did I claim max 3SAT-3?
Because we can use
this reduction now.
So there is another
reason I showed you this.
I haven't seen this explicitly
said in the literature,
but all the pieces
are out there.
So once you show max 3SAT
some constant is hard,
then you can do an L
reduction from that problem
to max 3SAT-3, just like this.
So first we do the expander.
And then, still these nodes
have too high a degree.
They're degree 29.
Now we're going to expand
those into little cycles
of constraints.
Now this is actually OK when
the cycle has constant length,
because maybe-- suppose some
of these are set to true,
some of them are set to false.
Then just set them all to false.
Don't even take majority.
Set them all to false.
How much does that hurt you?
Well, you know that
each of these variables
appeared in a constant
number of clauses.
So it only hurt you
by a constant amount.
Every time you flip a
variable from true to false,
you only lose an additive
constant in your solution.
So when we're converting from
a solution y-prime, which
does weird things on
a cycle, potentially,
when we convert it to y
and set them all to false,
we-- I mean we know--
so there's two cases.
One is, all of these
constraints are satisfied.
Then, you should choose
exactly what's written,
and then they will all
be true or all be false.
But if at least one
of them is violated,
you can charge to that violation
and set them all to false.
And when you do that, I don't
know how many-- you know,
at most 1,000 violations
happen, some constant.
Like three times 20-- whatever.
Some constant.
And then you know
that you can charge
that cost to the violation
that you were given in y-prime.
And so you can get that L
reduction property, too,
and say oh good,
the additive gap
in my produced solution where
I just set all those to false
is at most 1,000 times
the original additive gap.
And so that's an L
reduction from max 3SAT
constant to max 3SAT-3.
Questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how do you know
there's a constant number
of violations?
PROFESSOR: Because
now we were given
an instance of 3SAT
constant, meaning
each variable appears in a
constant number of clauses.
So we were given a
situation-- right, sorry.
Also, when we do this,
each-- we set it up
so each of these variables
appears in one original clause.
Yeah And we know the total
size of the cycle is constant.
So each of these, every time
we turn one of these to false,
we lose one point.
And there's only a
constant number of these,
so it's actually-- the
constant is only 27.
Or 29, sorry.
29.
It's a little weird to
get used to L reductions.
I'm still getting used to them.
But as you can see,
it's pretty powerful.
You can do a lot,
and it's just OK.
You definitely
have to be careful.
In general, you want things
to have bounded degree.
That makes things
really helpful.
That's why I'm telling you
about these two problems.
What next.
Let's just continue--
let me at least mention,
in case I run out
of time, max not all
equal 3SAT, also hard, positive
1 in 3SAT, even one in E3SAT.
Also, APX hard.
APX complete.
So those are good friends from
3SAT land to carry over here.
But let's prove some-- and I
will eventually prove those.
Let's prove some
other fun problems.
Next one is independent set.
Now I have to be a
little bit careful here.
Independent set is really
really, really hard.
But an interesting special
case is bounded degree
independent set.
So that's what I'll
talk about next.
I think I'm going to prove max
degree for independent set,
although it's known that
max degree 3 is hard also.
So constant degree independent
set is actually APX complete.
So there is a constant
factor approximation,
which is take any maximal
independent set-- just
keep adding vertices
until you can't anymore.
That will be within a factor of
this of optimal, you can show.
That's pretty clear.
So that puts it in APX.
And furthermore, we
claim that's [INAUDIBLE].
So there's a constant
factor, and there's also
a constant factor
in approximability.
Some constant you
cannot go below.
And the proof is this,
although it's a little bit--
so it's a reduction from,
let's say, the one we just did,
max 3SAT-3.
And it's going to be
a strict reduction.
We're not going to lose
anything if I did things right.
Now in fact-- so I drew
here six recurrences of xi,
but there's really
only three of them.
But the idea is
complete bipartite graph
between the positive
instances of xi
and the negative instances.
And then these are going
to be plugged in directly
to the clause gadgets.
These are the same variable.
And so the idea is
each of these was
plugged into only one clause.
So I need to make copies.
I do this complete bipartite
graph between them.
And now we're trying to do
max independent set, which
means whatever solution we find,
it will be an independent set.
That's cool.
There's no slack in
independence here.
It's just about
how many we choose.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What is
an independent set?
PROFESSOR:
Independence set is you
want to choose a set
of variables that
have no edges between them.
Sorry, instead of vertices,
they have no edges between them.
So that means that if I choose
any one of the blue nodes here,
I can't choose any of the
red nodes, and vice versa.
So I may not be able to
choose all of the blue
or all of the red, but
that's how it goes.
Now if we look at a clause,
there's-- in this case,
we have to actually handle
the case of clauses of size 2
and clauses of size 3.
If you have a clause
of size 3, you'd
just build a triangle on them.
And the idea is only one
of those can be chosen.
But it could be zero get chosen,
because you might be screwed.
Maybe you chose a
red xi, and then you
won't be able to
choose this blue xi.
Maybe you chose a red xj.
Maybe you chose a blue xk.
In that case, you
won't be able to choose
any of these vertices.
But if at least one
of these [INAUDIBLE]
is true, if you chose--
if you're either
choosing the blue xi's or the
blue xj's or the red xk's, then
in fact you get one
point for each clause.
And in general, the
number of points you get,
the number of things
you'll be able to put
into your independent
set, is exactly
the number of clauses
you'll be able to satisfy.
And just by looking at whether
any of the blue xi's are true,
then you set xi to true, looking
at whether any of the red xi's
are set-- are chosen
in the independent set,
then you set xi to false.
That will recover
the assignment,
and it'll have exactly the same
cost as the independent set
size.
Number of clauses you satisfy
will be exactly the number
of independent set size.
And similarly, for
a clause of size 2.
So that's cool.
Independent set is really easy
to reduce from max 3SAT-3.
In fact, it would work
for max 3SAT constant.
But if you do a max at
3SAT-3, there's only three
of these guys.
Then I think the biggest
degree you get is 4.
This guy maybe is
attached to two things,
and then also to two
things over here.
Great.
Next problem is vertex cover.
So this is a funny one.
So let's do a constant
degree vertex cover.
In general, there's a two
approximation for vertex cover.
So we don't need the constant
degree to be an APX, but.
This is also APX complete.
And it's kind of identical
to the independent set
in a funny way, which
is for any graph,
if you look at a vertex
cover, its complement
is an independent set.
If you look at any
independent set,
its complement is
a vertex cover.
Sorry, any maximal independent
set, its complement
is a vertex cover.
So they're kind of
duel in that, if you
look at the size
of a vertex cover
plus size of a maximal
independent set,
it will always equal
the number of vertices.
So maximizing this is the
same as minimizing this.
But approximating this
is not necessarily
the same as approximating this.
One's a maximization problem,
one's a minimization problem.
But it's still an L reduction
for bounded degree graphs,
because if you have
degree at most delta,
there's always an independent
set size of at least N
over delta.
And there's always a
vertex cover of size N.
So they're within constant
factors of each other.
In fact, these are both always
theta the number of vertices.
OK?
So the reduction is you give me
an instance of independent set,
I give you that exact same
instance to vertex cover.
And then-- so f is trivial.
G takes the complement.
Whatever you had in
the vertex cover,
you don't put it in
the independent set,
and vice versa.
And then you just have to check
that this is an L reduction.
So the first thing is the OPTs
are within a constant factor
of each other.
That's true, because they're
both within a constant factor
of the number of vertices.
And then you prove that
the additive gap is fixed.
And it's the same thing if you
decrement this accidentally,
then you increment
this accidentally.
They're one for one.
So this is kind of cool.
It feels a little scary, but
we can convert a maximization
problem into a minimization
problem with L reductions.
This would be very hard
to even think about
in the other
reduction types, which
is one of the reasons L
reductions are so successful,
I think.
That was vertex cover.
We can do one more.
OK, really easy.
Dominating set.
Remember, dominating
set-- with vertex cover,
when you put a
vertex in your cover,
you cover all the
edges incident to it,
and you want to
cover all the edges.
Dominating set, when
you put a vertex in,
you cover all the
neighboring vertices.
You want to cover all vertices.
So I'm going to reduce
from vertex cover.
If you have an edge,
what you do is convert it
into a path of length
2 plus that edge.
So then you know that, if
this is in the dominating set,
you can just move it
over to [INAUDIBLE] or w.
It will cover all the things
it could cover before,
and maybe even more.
So then in the optimal
solution over here,
you'd never need to choose
one of these vertices, which
means we can assume that on the
original vertices, which means
you are just solving
vertex cover,
because covering that is the
same as covering that edge.
Good.
I think that's good for now.
We'll do a bunch more
reductions next time.